[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors effectivement on va transposer ce
que le sport nous a appris en termes de
dynamique collective de performance
collectif vers ce que vous dans vos
entités dans vos organisations dans vos
classes dans vos groupes dans vos écoles
dans vos équipes
vous pouvez éventuellement utiliser donc
tout vient vraiment du terrain c'est du
terrain c'est du coaching c'est du
basique mais ce sont des choses
extrêmement efficace qui marche puisque
le sport permet effectivement de tester
l'efficacité est la validité de certains
outils alors le sport collectif est un
sujet sur lequel je me penche depuis
maintenant une vingtaine d'années le
sport individuel avant ça maintenant je
cours collectifs est-ce que je vais
partager avec vous c'est l'expérience
accumulée en termes de leadership
collaboratif qu'est ce que ça veut dire
du collaboratif et participatif
qu'est ce qui fait que une collection de
joueurs d'individus envie de jouer
ensemble et vont créer effectivement un
ciment une colle tellement fort que le
solidaire la solidarité l'unité la
cohésion peut éventuellement compenser
parfois un certain moment un manque de
talent ou un manque d'individualisme
donc ce travail sur le collectif est un
travail vraiment capital pour la
réussite le networking aujourd'hui le
participatif le collaboratif deviennent
des éléments clé dans la réussite
alors comment sont peut-être par une une
image qui permettent peut-être mieux
comprendre le sujet alors quand on parle
de collaboratif ici on
j'étais impressionné tout à l'heure par
l'autre présentation sur les écluses des
galaxies imaginons ici une galaxie
d'individus d'equipe d'entités ça peut
être des classes à peu des équipes ça
peut être des pays est effectivement
l'expertisé là chacun dans son domaine
est extrêmement maîtrisant mais il ya
peu de connexions ça reste ce qu'on
appelle des silos l'étape numéro deux
c'est comment est ce qu'on arrive à
connecter les silos mon travail n'est
pas de connecter les silos on travaille
c'est d'aller à l'étape numéro 3 avec
une connexion de silos on n'arrive à
rien c'est pas parce que les silos se
parle c'est pas parce que les silos
partage qu'on va arriver à performer
qu'on va arriver à gagner donc l'étape
numéro 2 est une étape intéressante est
une étape intermédiaire c'est là qu'on
va chercher la performance c'est là on
va chercher les médailles
c'est là qu'on va chercher effectivement
les exploits dans la phase numéro 3 et
la phase numéro trois c'est ce qui fait
que d'un
d'individus connectés interconnecté
d'entités de pays d'organisation
d'entreprise on arrive à créer quelque
chose qui fait la valeur ajoutée et avec
les mêmes points avec les mêmes desseins
on arrive à créer quelque chose qui
devient une vraie une image une valeur
ajoutée qu'est ce qu'on va créer
ensemble et ça c'est la dynamique
effectivement de la performance
collective c'est pas simplement
additionner des individus et les
connecter ça allait plus loin avec la
connexion beaucoup plus loin que la
connexion qui fait que cette connexion
on va créer vraiment une valeur ajoutée
qui nous permet de performer donc on va
partager sur ce saut entre l'étape de l
étape 3 qu'est ce qui fait que de là on
peut arriver là vous êtes tous dans des
équipes vous êtes dans des classes vous
êtes dans des groupes où êtes vous
aujourd'hui si vous vous situez par
rapport aux 3 vous êtes toujours dans
une des équipes déconnecté pas assez
connectés ou alors on connecte en
partage mais il n'y a pas vraiment de
valeur ajoutée ou alors vous êtes déjà
en phase iii où effectivement il ya
quelque chose qui se passe qui nous
permet de produire des résultats
j'imagine que l'équipe qui a organisé
cet événement ce soir elle a démarré par
une constellation d'individus qui se
sont rassemblés connectés qui finissent
par créer la magie dont on profite tous
ce soir
comment est-ce qu'on crée cette
dynamique on va revoir le processus
calmement et on va essayer de le
comprendre et de le détailler
alors quand on parle de ce processus de
dynamique collective voilà quand on
parle de ce processus de dynamique
collective l'énergie collective ça
marche
arrivé là je vais venir
vous l'avez oui donc le métier de
travail sur le coaching sportif est un
travail on est constamment dans
l'intuition dans le moment on n'est pas
dans le powerpoint donc aujourd'hui j'ai
des idées sur ce que je pourrais
partager avec vous mais c'est beaucoup
le moment l'intuition l'atmosphère qui
fait que je vais partir vers un sujet ou
un autre on crée toujours en direct
c'est le principe de base du coaching
donc c'est en dire est que les
événements se crée donc c'est peut-être
moins beau c'est peut-être moins propre
mais en tout cas
et plus efficace c'est ce qu'ont sport
on appelle l'imparfait efficace
l'imparfait efficace qui est une
dimension importante de la performance
dans beaucoup d'organisation quel est le
contraire de imparfait efficace le
contraire d'un pare feu efficaces c'est
le parfait inefficace il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont dans du parfait inefficace
recherche de perfection le détail le
souci etc
qu'est ce qu'on perd que mme énergie eau
et on perd en efficacité
donc l'imparfait efficace et ses erreurs
personne n'est parfait
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on doit essayer
de produire des choses parfaite
personnes dont à partir du moment où on
est imparfait efficace on ose essayer on
ose pratiqué en hausse tenter des choses
c'est la pare feu efficace qui nous aide
à progresser la perfection elle nous
bloque l'excellence est une succession
d'essais et d'erreurs de learning
d'apprentissage comment est ce que je
vais apprendre l'énergie collective
elle s'analyse sur deux dimensions
principalement elle s'analyse d'un côté
sur la dimension intra team dimension
numéro un est la dimension intérim ses
dimensions numéro deux il faut bien
distinguer aujourd'hui quand on
travaille sur du participé du
collaboratif quel est le collaboratif
dans l'équipe comment est-ce qu'une
addition d'individus peut proposer
effectivement une équipe gagnant comment
quand je mets la pression sur une équipe
ses équipes au lieu d'exploser cette
équipe elle va se rapprocher
ça c'est l'impératif dans l'équipe
comment est-ce qu'on crée de la colle et
du simone de la dynamique l'intérim cg
une équipe super g une deuxième équipe
super comment est-ce que ces deux
équipes vont travailler ensemble
ça c'est de l'intérim le collaboratif
c'est à la fois de l'intra type et c'est
parfois de l'intérim dans certains
organisation le défi n'est pas un tradi
les équipes fonctionnent bien elles ne
se parlent pas dans d'autres cas les
équipes sont collectées mais dans chaque
équipe il ya trop de tensions trop de
perte d'énergie
donc on va analyser les deux dimensions
quand on parle aujourd'hui de
performance collective il faut bien
distinguer d'un côté le leadership et de
l'autre côté comme vous l'avez vu sur le
slide le membership réussir aujourd'hui
à
une équipe c'est à la fois développer du
leadership mais surtout développé du
membership dont beaucoup d'organisation
il ya un excès d'attention sur le
leadership
on veut des gens de plus en plus lead le
livre c'est l'impact verticale le leader
ses inspirations ses énergies c'est la
guide ans le leader le travail du livre
c'est indispensable
la motivation principale la définition
fondamentale basiques d'un leader c'est
créer de l'énergie positive
qu'est ce qu'on attend d'un livre qu'ils
créent de l'énergie et cette énergie
elle peut venir du futur de l'ambition
de la direction de l'exemplarité le
principe de base du leadership s'écrier
créiez de l'énergie positive
est ce que dans vos métiers aujourd'hui
dans vos organisations vous créiez cette
énergie positive
je connais beaucoup de gens qui se
positionne comme leader qui se voudrait
leader mais qui n'en n'ont pas les
attributs ni les comportements à la fin
de la réunion à la fin du meeting tout
le monde est épuisé il coûte de
l'énergie au lieu dans la porte et le
leadership c'est la création d'énergie
c'est le point
à côté de ça vous avez le membership et
le membership sais comment je transforme
l'énergie transformée transformées en
actions ça c'est du membership le
membership sans le leadership n'est rien
c'est le leadership qui crée l'énergie
parce qu'il ya une intention parce qu'il
ya une aspiration parce qu'une
inspiration
parce qu'une mobilisation parce qu une
exemplarité ça c'est le leadership
quand l'énergie a été créé il faut la
transformer en actions sans
transformation d'action sans cohésion
y'a rien qui peut se passer s'est
transformé en actions en actions
cohésion ensemble en actions support on
se donne de l'aide on demande de l'aide
ici la création d'énergie positive c'est
surtout l'inspiration un travail de
leadership c'est de l'inspiration et
deuxième élément c'est de l'exemplarité
deux éléments de base du leadership
donc aujourd'hui dans vos organisations
à ce que le leadership est assez
puissant pour créer cette énergie est ce
que le membership et assez puissant pour
le transformer en actions le leadership
est une énergie verticale
j'ai impact sur l'organisation
verticalement le membership et une auris
un impact horizontale leadership
l'impact membership je connecte
je connais beaucoup d'équipés j'en ai
coach et où le leadership des joueurs
sur le terrain apprend de prise de
décisions audace courage initiative
extraordinaire mais le membership très
faible on peut avoir une addition
d'excellents joueurs super lead mais qui
ne sont pas des bons membres
aujourd'hui les grandes équipes elles
combinent la magie à la fois de leaders
capables de décider d'assumer et de
membres capables de connecter de ce
supporter de s'assister et de
s'encourager leadership et membership
c'est ce sont les deux les deux
paramètres principaux quand on parle de
leadership aujourd'hui il faut être
conscient que dans le leadership vous
devez travailler sur deux axes
principaux
si je travaille sur du leadership je
dois travailler d'un côté sur ce qu'on
appelle du arc de l'autre sceau du teil
l'autre axe et du qi et l'autre axe et
du cul le leadership a beaucoup évolué
quand on veut travailler sur un
leadership de participation le leader
aujourd'hui c'est plus simplement
tél jeudi je donne un ordre je donne une
instruction je donne une solution
cette venue beaucoup due à ascq et donc
sur la chaîne aujourd'hui entre télé as
le leadership est quelque chose qui a
beaucoup évolué avant c'était
principalement du teil aujourd'hui c'est
devenu beaucoup du havre avant c'était
du qi
je donne des idées je donne des
instructions je donne des solutions
aujourd'hui c'est devenu beaucoup du
assure qu avec le hamas
on implique ask égale impliqués ça s'est
impliqué avec toute la partie avec toute
la partie que vous mettez sur le jeu
revient dessus
voilà le retrouve ça c'est la magie de
la technologie
ici je suis sur la partie impliquée en
suis je suis sur la partie expliquée
dans beaucoup de cas pendant 10 15 ans
j'étais un manager tél j'étais payé pour
l' expertise j'étais devant mes joueurs
j'essaie de les convaincre
maintenant je suis un manager race
comment
vous voyez le match qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait faire qu'est ce que tu en
penses
et si on est derrière si on est devant
qu'est ce qu'on va faire et donc les
gens sont beaucoup plus impliqués et
canton débrief le match c'est pas que du
débriefing rationnelle il ya beaucoup
d'émotion elle qu'est-ce que vous êtes
senti dans le match comment vous sentez
maintenant quand vous sentez avant le
match il ya beaucoup d'émotions dead la
partie aujourd'hui qui est la moins
utilisée c'est cette partie là je pense
que le leadership du futur sera de plus
en plus un leadership qui va stimuler le
casque sûr qu on le voit venir la
nouvelle génération des tests l'hôtel
cuit le manager reconnaît qui donne la
solution et qu'il impose ses plus hauts
managers là qui va réussir demain le
manager qui implique le manager
effectivement qui involves qu'un pauvre
celui là il peut encore réussir demain
donc le management aujourd'hui
d'implication c'est un management qui
principalement va tourner plus vers le
hamas
on pose on implique les joueurs dans les
dents les décision n'implique les
collaborateurs les participants les
élèves les employés et deuxièmement
beaucoup sur l'émotionnel le futur du
leadership c'est le assure qu e le futur
du leadership c'est le membership au
delà du leadership
comment est ce que je vais arriver
effectivement à jouer mon rôle de membre
je peux être leader d'une équipe mais
toujours être membre également de cette
équipe
donc quand on parle de membership l'on
travaille plutôt sur les critères de
membership qui sont différents si je
reviens sur quelques critères de base le
premier critère de leadership c'est
d'abord le travail sur la collaboration
hashtag collaboration membership hashtag
collaboration c'est le premier c'est pas
simplement moi je garde le ballon je ne
passe pas la balle à neymar ou à cavani
mais effectivement les deux joueurs
apprennent à se passer la balle enfin ça
arrivera peut-être un jour on verra donc
aujourd'hui on peut avoir beaucoup de
leadership
mais c'est le manque de membership qui
fait qu'on va peut-être pas gagné cette
compétition on va peut-être pas éliminé
le real de madrid qu'on va peut-être pas
passer au tour suivant
parce que les joueurs sont bons mais ce
qui joue assez ensemble
sk cette solidarité est ce qu'à ce
ciment il ya cette colle cette énergie
cette dynamique donc acheté
collaboration acheta confiance aussi si
je passe la balle à l'autre c'est parce
que je pense qu'il est
pas de la reprendre qu'il va capable de
l'utiliser si je donne une fonction une
mission parce que je pense qu'il est
capable effectivement de correctement le
travail et hashtag confiance ici vous
allez avoir aussi hashtag la partie team
first c'est l'équipe d'abord c'est pas
mon intérêt d'abord qu'est-ce qui a
comme hashtag intéressant aussi c'est
hashtag respect respect respect des
règles respect de l'adversaire respect
donc il ya beaucoup de hashtag
aujourd'hui quand on mesure aujourd'hui
la qualité d'un travail sur le
membership
on travaille l'évaluation se fait sur
deux niveaux
l'évaluation c'est d'un côté la
productivité qu'est-ce que tu produis
pour l'équipe / le coût d'énergie
[Musique]
l'énergie est inclus dans toutes les
formules d'évaluation c'est bien de
produire de marquer des goals de
produire des résultats
mais qu'est ce que tu coûtes à l'équipe
en termes de popper d'énergie arrogance
en terme de jeu arrive en retard à la
réunion
tu es constamment sur ton laptop ce ton
smartphone pendant que le coach est
occupé à briefer donc on évalue les deux
dimensions d'un côté merci pour ce que
tu produis et nous en sommes
reconnaissants et on va effectivement le
mesurer et d'un autre côté vous avez le
coût d'énergie qui évalue sa jamais le
trend jamais l'entraîneur toujours les
teams mettre sous jours les
collaborateurs toujours utiliser la
puissance de l'équipe arrêté d'utiliser
la puissance du lied c'est l'équipe qui
à un certain moment va évaluer la
contribution
la valeur des autres joueurs merci
d'avoir bien joué d'avoir marqué de
gaulle mais à côté de ça il ya des
assises que tu n'as pas fait une arrivée
en retard ou tu es toujours sur ton
téléphone tu n'es pas toujours dit dans
dans l'écouté et c'est donc quand on
évalue un joueur on dévalue d'un petit
sa productivité
/ son coût d'énergie le grand alex
ferguson disait que la formule devait
être supérieur à 3 supérieur à 3
un joueur était rentable quand ils
produisaient trois fois plus qu'il ne
coûtaient et le productivité se mesure
la coût énergétique se mesure aussi avec
des paramètres qu'on arrive à un certain
moment à identifier quand on travaille
sur du collaboratif et du membership
il faut bien se dire un certain moment
aussi que vous avez différents types de
joueurs vous avez des joueurs dans une
équipe on appelle les tigers différents
types de competo compte de compréhension
d'un côté vous avez les tigers
ensuite vous avez les matchs hors ce
deuxième catégorie 3e catégorie ce sont
les diverses
les tigers c'est les mecs qui viennent y
prennent ils viennent assister à cette
conférence ici ils prennent mais ils
vont rien repartager ils vont bien et a
distribué vieira ils vont rien raconté
ils gardent pour eux très égocentrique y
en a quelques-uns peut être d'ici on les
repère intéressant dans toutes les
équipes il ya des tigers
ils viennent mais ils viennent prendre
pour s'être sl saintrick très
égocentrique
je prends je prends les matchs horse
c'est une deuxième catégorie sont mieux
parce que ils négocient je veux bien
donner de lège bien apporter du support
mais qu'est ce que j'aurais en retour
c'est les matches ça négocie les give
her say vous organisez ce soir un
événement qu'est ce que je peux faire
pour aider ces gens là ils sont là en
soutien en support mais ce n'est pas
encore suffisant si on veut aller au
niveau olympique
si on veut aller au top niveau il faut
rentrer dans la catégorie de ce qu'on
appelle les booster ce les boosters
c'est mieux que les diverses légumes
verts s'ils donnent du temps et de
l'énergie donne de l'aide les booster et
donne la créativité
il donne de l'inspiration ils donnent de
l'imagination et on pourrait faire ça et
on pourrait faire ça en plus
et la prochaine fois on fera comme ça
les pousse torse qui sont les gens dans
vos équipes qui sont dans la première la
deuxième la troisième ou la quatrième
catégorie
vous avez encore une catégorie au dessus
on les appelle les bridgeurs les
bridgeurs ce sont ceux qui sont capables
de créer des ponts des ponts avec
d'autres équipes de trouver des
alliances trouver des partenaires chip
de trouver d inspiration c'est les gens
qui au delà de la cellule de l'équipe
vont chercher quelque chose en plus à
l'extérieur
ce qui crée des ponts et donc
probablement votre équipe ici
d'événements ce soir il y avait des
bridgeurs qui sont allés chercher à
l'extérieur des ponts des alliances d
inspiration et donc où sont vos joueurs
aujourd'hui par rapport à ça quand on
travaille sur ces joueurs là il faut
bien se dire que la puissance de
l'équipe
elle se travaille beaucoup sur
l'émotionnel j'ai une mauvaise nouvelle
pour vous nous sommes dans une
institution effectivement académique
très mauvaise nouvelle pour vous
l'intelligence le qi n'est pas
contagieux vous n'allez jamais contaminé
personnes avec votre intelligence
l'émotion est contagieuse le choeur est
contagieux l'enthousiasmé contagieux
l'énergie est contagieuse donc un
certain moment c'est bien d'être
travaillé avec le cerveau mecque le
cerveau c'est pas suffisant pour arriver
au sommet il faut plus que du cerveau et
de l'intelligence pour arriver il faut
du coeur il faut des tripes il faut du
courage il faut de l'envy faut de la
passion
quand on travaille sur les deux sujets
que vous est présenté tout à l'heure
l'intra team et l'intérim
je voudrais vous donner un ou deux
éléments intra un ou deux éléments
concrets intra team
on appelle ça le intra team glou c'est à
dire la colle intra team qu'est ce qui
fait que la attractive à fonctionner et
là vous avez effectivement dans l'intra
steam cloud vous avez trois paramètres
qui font que la colle va fonctionner un
tracking glousser 1 l'objectif commun
est ce que l'équipe a un objectif commun
tant que l'objectif n'est pas clair il
ya rien qui peut marcher
2 c'est le cadre commun le cadre ce sont
les règles dans mon cas je rentre dans
le village olympique avec un cadre le
cadre c'est les règles du dopage règles
du dopage dans le cadre où tu es peut
participer au regarde tu pourrais
peut-être être éliminé voir disqualifier
donc un objectif commun il ya un cadre
commun le troisième élément c'est la
confiance commune
si vous voulez dans vos équipes
développer la dynamique collective
la colle dans une équipe c'est
l'objectif commun le cadre commun et la
confiance mutuelle qu'est ce qui vous
manque dans vos équipes aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est l'objectif qui est pas
clair est ce que c'est le cadre et les
raies
qui sont pas claires ou c'est la
confiance qui n'est pas assez clair un
certain moment si on veut passer le cap
il faut passer sur ses dimensions là
quand on travaille sur le intertice blue
un terreau team jungle où on travaille
sur trois autres paramètres le un
terreau team jungle où travaillent sur
un sur la notion ici deux sens le sens
commun la mission commune il ya quelque
chose qui doit rassembler les équipes
qui est quelque chose de plus global qui
est le sens le pourquoi
le deuxième élément ce sont les valeurs
c'est pas du cadre c'est pas des règles
sont des valeurs qui me rapproche quand
les pays se rapprochent c'est parce
qu'il ya un sens commun un intérêt
commun et des valeurs communes et le
troisième que élément c'est la fierté
d'appartenance la fierté qui fait que le
joueur quand il a marqué un goal il va
faire comme ça je les fais pour le
blason pour l'écusson savez ya des
joueurs qui font le contraire
au lieu de montrer ça comment ils font
quand ils marquent un goal ils se
tournent ils font comme ça oui la
différence entre le team player
collectif membership et le solo plaire
celui qui est égocentrique centré sur
lui pas centré sur les autres comment
est ce qu'on arrive à coacher ces gens
là bas c'est d'abord les faire entrer
dans le cadre rappelé qu'un objectif
commun et créer une confiance commune
à partir de là on peut travailler quand
on travaille et bien c'est toujours un
travail sur le travail sur l'émotionnel
l'implication élan et l' enthousiasme et
pour boucler ce partage sur l'énergie
collaborative et sur le management
participatif
je voudrais vous montrer deux images qui
sont illustratifs de ce que je voulais
expliquer la première image c'est celle
ci quand on travaille sur le membership
il faut savoir que le leadership est
très visible le leader est visible le
membership c'est plutôt cette image là
le membership n'est pas visible mais
l'important n'est pas toujours visible
et parfois ont montré ce matin tout à
l'heure l'iceberg cette image qui montre
une autre forme effectivement de valeur
ajoutée la deuxième image du membership
c'est celle là
quand on parle de membership là on va
dans le mauvais sens
le collaboratif le partage la
coresponsabilité s'est arrêté de se
sentir que le trou n'est pas de notre
côté
et enfin la dernière image que je
voulais partager avec vous sur le côté
collaboratif sur le côté initiative
vous voyez les trois longues queues que
nous voyons ici la première c'est là que
classique pour critiquer toujours
beaucoup de monde pour critiquer dans la
deuxième que on a les gens qui disent ce
qu'il faut faire dans la troisième c'est
ce qu'ils font ce qu'ils agissent et
j'espère que c'est dans cette catégorie
là que vous allez vous retrouver
merci
[Applaudissements]